we're just a month away from the
premiere of frozen 2 and fans can't wait
to see what unfolds in the sequel to the
beloved Disney film audiences are
especially hopeful that the film will
finally reveal something many of us have
been wondering since frozen was released
in 2013
King agna and Queen Adina of arendelle
played a smaller critical role in frozen
at the beginning of the film they hide a
young Elsa away in an attempt to control
her powers putting a wedge between her
and Anna just a few scenes into the
movie they board a ship leaving their
now grown daughters in arendelle their
ship wrecked after being caught in a
storm and the crown falls to Elsa now if
frozen to remains true to Disney formula
which seems to with few exceptions leave
its protagonists either orphaned or with
one living parent than Elsa and Anna's
parents are dead
the frozen 2 trailer that dropped in
June however makes us think that things
might be headed in another direction the
trailer opens with Elsa growing into her
powers battling tidal waves underwater
she encounters a mythical Norse water
spirit called a nook Elsa and Anna then
embark on a quest urged on by the troll
grandpoppy who delivers an ominous
warning the past is not what it seems
we also see Queen Adina in trailer
footage some fans have taken all of this
to mean that one or both of Elsa and
Anna's parents are still alive and that
one of them may have powers of their own
that enabled them to survive the
shipwreck there's also speculation that
the water horse was sent as a message to
Elsa and Anna to tell them that the
shipwreck hadn't been fatal this ties
into other fan theories that came out
after frozen's release one such theory
speculates that Elsa and Anna's parents
might also be Tarzan's parents while the
man and woman in Tarzan don't really
look like king ogner and Queen Adina
Tarzan's parents did end up stranded
following a shipwreck even frozen's
director Chris buck said that he liked
this theory in Bach's imagination King
agna and
Doudna don't die he told MTV News that
in his mind they get shipwrecked and
somehow they really washed way far away
from the Scandinavian waters and they
end up in the jungle they end up
building a tree house and a leopard
kills them so their baby boy is raised
by gorillas he also added so in my
little head Anna and Elsa's brother is
Tarzan but on the other side of that
island are surfing penguins to tie in
with non Disney movie Surf's Up that's
my fun little world another favorite fan
Theory connects Elsa and armours parents
to the Little Mermaid and tangled could
the sunken ship we see in the Little
Mermaid actually belonged to King agna
and Queen Adina according to this theory
Elsa and Anna's parents were on their
way to Rapunzel and Flynn wedding when
their ship crashed leaving it for Ariel
to one day Explorer from there Rapunzel
and Flynn feel guilty for the deaths of
Elsa and Anna's parents leading them to
attend Elsa's coronation three years
later it's not a lot to go on but the
theories and the trailer do give us some
hope that Elsa and armours parents
survived the terrible shipwreck will
frozen to see the king and queen
reunited with Elsa and Anna giving them
a chance to be a happy family with no
more secrets between them it's true that
Disney has a habit of making its
princesses orphans but Disney films are
even better known for their happy
endings we'll have to wait until frozen
to premieres on November 22nd to find
out for sure check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite staff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]